johnny was here see if Michael Keaton is
in the Johnny Depp had a big day Monday
making Pink's dreams come true and
sporting a new do I think pink would
really really like a little bit of Jimmy
Kimmel surprised the singer by bringing
out her celeb crush her reaction turning
beet red
go away you literate you guys this also
on monday ET caught up with Johnny and
his messy new look at the big premiere
of Alice do the looking glass
I like the short hair oh yeah well then
he say I cut it for a thing did you
always have a relaxed vibe on the
carpets and so I was wondering what your
red carpet pregame was oh I just
shouldn't kohung go home man oh man that
we're getting close oh god oh god oh god
why yeah here it is the movie star we'll
have to make some room in that car for
his daughter lily-rose who was the face
of Chanel's new fragrance lastly how
proud are you of your daughter Lily and
her incredible Chanel campaign because
she is stunning Wow I'm I'm um I'm
incredibly proud you know it's but it's
like it's this thing that all right you
know I didn't expect that all this soon
she's you know she's handling it
beautifully she's got a good head on her
shoulders and she's very flattered and
she's doing a great job around she's
killing me